bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur public sénat pour la
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
c'est en ce qui va démarrer d'ici quinze
minutes mais avant nous recevrons alain
vidalies sts ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement bonjour
merci d'être avec nous juste pour nos
téléspectateurs parmi les thèmes qui
vont être révoqué cet après-midi lors de
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement et bien au moins trois
questions sur l'école et la réforme des
rythmes scolaires mais également des
interrogations des sénateurs sur
l'intervention au mali ou encore le
texte qui a été rejeté par le sénat la
semaine dernière autour des scrutins
électoraux nous y reviendrons donc eu
tout à l'heure alain vidalis pour
commencer donc florence cassez qui a été
libéré hier soir au mexique qui est
arrivé il ya un peu plus d'une heure
maintenant sur le sol français et déjà
la polémique politique qui enfle entre
l'ancien président le nouveau président
celui qui aurait le plus facilité la
libération de la française
est-ce que vous avez pas plutôt vous
envie de vous réjouir aujourd'hui je
crois que tout le monde devrait avoir
envie de se réjouir pour elle pour sa
famille pour les gens qui vont aider
pendant toutes ces années franchement je
trouve que là la polémique n'a pas cela
n'a pas sa place dans cette affaire et
pourtant elle est relayée par des
politiques de premier plan et compris
par des ministres par des personnalités
de droite
est-ce que c'est pas tout simplement les
deux personnalités des deux prêts dans
le public l'ancien nouveau qui ont
permis finalement à cette issue heureuse
ça sent quand il ya une issue heureuse
peu importe au fond c'est grâce à qui
c'est d'abord une décision de la justice
du mexique qui après les errements est
arrivé à prendre cette décision c'est ça
qui est important
chacun sait le rôle qu'a pu jouer
françois hollande dans cette affaire
mais ça ne remet pas en cause ce
qu'avait au moins essayer de faire
nicolas sarkozy je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de de hiérarchie à faire chacun se fera
son opinion
franchement je trouve débat sur le
mérite de chacun
c'est assez déplacé en tout cas florence
cassez sera reçu demain
à l'élysée avec sa famille par le
président de la république françois
hollande une autre information qui a été
publié par certains médias ce matin
autour des 75 % dans la position des 75%
il paraît que le gouvernement y
renoncerait est ce que c'est vrai c'est
pas vrai c'est faut donc je vais faire
une seule réponse pour que ça évite
encore des commentaires la réponse est
non le gouvernement reviendra sur ces 75
% ou en tout cas un taux qui avoisine
les 75 % la réponse est oui
comme ça au moins les choses sont
claires l'information de ce matin est
fausse et donc nous allons à présenter
un texte qui obéira aux mêmes objectifs
que le texte initial et tiendra compte
des objections juridiques faite par le
conseil constitutionnel en peut pas être
plus clair que ça et quand et dans quel
texte quel est le calendrier alors un
texte ce sera forcément un texte
budgétaire ça me va être autrement donc
forcément à l'horizon de la prochaine
loi de finances rectificative
on ne connaît pas la date mais c'est le
mois d'avril europe lutter avril ou même
la fin du printemps début de l'été les
siens donc pas avancer tête est fini si
vous pensez que le mois d'avril c'est le
sait c'est l'été pas moi d'accord mais
quelle marche vous laisse le conseil
constitutionnel a votre avis il nous
demande de revoir notre copie puisque il
a estimé qu' on ne pouvait pas taxer les
gens à titre individuel je rappelle que
c'est ça le problème
parce que la fiscalité se fait par
ménage donc faut qu'on arrive soit à
réintroduire dans la fiscalité par
ménage mais c'est compliqué mais ça fait
partie des objets des idées qui sont à
l'étude soit d'avoir une assiette qui se
situe en amont c'est à dire à la source
voilà bon c'est assez compliquée
techniquement mais on a aussi sur le
seuil maximal d'imposition possible sans
atteindre un niveau trop compliqué tout
risque à part ça c'est pas la décision
du conseil constitutionnel
mais c'est l'une des 150 naturellement
vous avez
verizon sur ce point mais l'information
de ce matin n'a strictement aucun
contenu crédibles concernant la réforme
autour du cumul des mandats est ce que
là vous avez un calendrier un peu plus
précis à nous annoncer siens tout à fait
le texte passera en conseil des
ministres le 27 février je peux pas être
plus précis donc tout ce que je lis sur
les interrogations ils le feront jamais
ou y aura pas de texte vous donne la
réponse
le texte sur le cumul des mandats le
projet présenté par le président de la
république en conseil des ministres sera
présenté le 27 février
je précise 2013 et 2013 c'est à dire
dans quelques jours donc dans quelques
jours on va savoir à ce que repose le
gouvernement là et notamment quand sera
applicable à ces supputations du cumul
des mandats doctement ont connu on
connaît à peu près l'assiette c'est à
dire que ça s'appliquera à tout le monde
et de manière égale donc les députés et
les sénateurs
est ce que je ne peux pas vous préciser
c'est l'entrée en application puisque on
a des élus qui ont des échéances
différentes et donc il ya plusieurs
solutions mais dans quelle politique
n'est pas encore arbitré la date
d'application de cette invitation du cul
ça n'est pas encore définitivement
arbitré donc je ne peux pas donné cette
indication dans tous les cas ce sera
dans quelques jours et vous avez vous
une préférence entre 2014 et 2017
je pense que le jour où un ministre
décidera de donner des indications sur
ses positions personnelles il vaudrait
mieux qu'ils changent d'activité donc en
conseil des ministres le 27 février et
l'examen ensuite au parlement à
l'assemblée au sénat
oui l'exode suite à l'assemblée et au
sénat avec un objectif qui est là je
peux vous donner des précisions que ce
texte soit définitivement adopté quelle
que soit sa date d'application ensuite
dans le temps mais qu'il soit
définitivement adopté avant le 15
septembre
dans tous les cas est ce qu il est vrai
que le gouvernement veut une session
extraordinaire assez dense et dds que
les parlementaires vont travailler au
moins jusqu'à la fin du mois de juillet
si ce n'est au mois d'août
naturellement c'est pas une volonté du
gouvernement mais quand on regarde tous
les textes importants qui sont qui sont
inscrits l'année sur le texte sur le
mariage mia le texte sur les cols les
plus le texte sur l'université la
réforme
de l'université suivi d'un texte la
réforme constitutionnelle le cumul des
mandats chacun comprend bien de fait
qu'il faudra qu'il y ait à un moment
donné une ou plusieurs sessions
extraordinaires le mariage pour tous
vous l'évoquiez à l'instant discussion à
partir de la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée nationale et puis sans doute
aux alentours peut-être de la mi mars
ici au sénat est ce que vous allez
laisser tout le temps aux parlementaires
pour examiner ce texte mais écoutez il
ya une décision qui a été prise par ce
gouvernement qui a pas été commentées
mais qui aurait dû l'être de montreuil
de mon point de vue dans tous les cas
c'est que nous avions une arme à notre
disposition qui avait d'ailleurs été
inventé par la droite quand il était au
pouvoir
ce qu'on appelle le temps programmé
c'est à dire qu'on décide avant que le
débat va durer que 50 heures ou 80
heures etc
c'est pour éviter l'obstruction afin de
leur éviter l'obstruction nous avons
décidé de ne pas utiliser le temps
programmé
donc il n'ya pas de temps programmé ceux
qui veulent un débat aurons un débat et
ça durera autant que nécessaire voilà
pourquoi nous avons ouvert l'assemblée
nationale à partir de mardi soir pendant
deux semaines
tous les jours la nuit comprise y
compris le week-end
qu'en est il du projet de loi annoncé
sur la famille avec notamment les
fameuses dispositions sur la pma la
procréation médicale assistée est ce que
vous avez un calendrier pour ce texte
sur la famille tout à fait je peux aussi
vous donner une réponse ce texte devra
sera examiné en conseil des ministres le
27 mars
parce que là aussi il ya des
parlementaires qui s'inquiète notamment
chez les écologistes qui disent ok il y
aura pas la pma dans le projet de loi
sur le mariage pour tous mais on n'a pas
de vision sur ce texte sur la famille
mais c'est normal que vous relayer ses
inquiétudes
ici je ne peux pas être plus précis vous
me posez une question sur le cumul des
mandats je vous donne la date du conseil
des ministres une question sur le sur la
famille je vous donne la date du conseil
des ministres donc voilà à toutes ces
questions on est aujourd'hui amenés à
donner des réponses très précises donc
vous rassurer noël mamère qui
s'interroge est ce matin dans la presse
sur l'existence y aura une taxe aux
textes le 27 mars ce qui est prévu
un autre écologiste sénateurs cette fois
c'est jean vincent placé
il dit qu'il n'est pas sûr de voter le
projet de loi qui appliquera l'accord
paritaire autour de l'emploi qu'est ce
qu'on pensait sa position mais je suis
en désaccord avec sa position mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on engage le débat
qu'on en discute
il ya deux choses dans cette affaire il
ya d'une part l'appréciation sur le
contenu du texte lui-même où on peut
avoir une appréciation différente de son
contenu et puis il ya les règles qu'on
essaye de respecter devant l'existence
d'un accord entre les partenaires
sociaux
et là il faut être très attentif ça fait
partie des engagements du président de
la république d'avoir un nouveau système
un nouveau rapport à la démocratie
sociale c'est à dire les accords entre
les partenaires sociaux
et d'ailleurs ça sera inscrit dans la
constitution puisque dans la réforme
constitutionnelle qui aura lieu
vraisemblablement fin juillet il y aura
cette reconnaissance de la démocratie
sociale et donc là on efface plutôt je
dirais une question de méthode et de
principe sur jusqu'où on va par rapport
aux textes qui ont été signés par les
partenaires sociaux si on veut ce qui
est le souhait de jean vincent placé et
celui du gouvernement
si on veut que à l'avenir une continue à
y avoir dans ce pays des négociations
entre les partenaires sociaux et dans
les entreprises réforme accord entre les
partenaires sociaux qui a été saluée par
l'ensemble du gouvernement y compris
cécile duflot jean vincent placé cécile
duflot c'est le même parti ça repose une
nouvelle fois encore la question de la
place dès que les écologistes au sein du
gouvernement
écouter jusqu'à présent personne et vous
pouvez pas me donner un exemple n'a pris
les écologistes à défaut par rapport à
la solidarité gouvernementale ils sont
au gouvernement
et cet engagement il le respecte nous
n'avons pas tous les textes du
gouvernement alain vidalies st
l'engagement de la majorité
gouvernementale c'est les textes
fondamentaux le budget la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
il ya des discussions sur leur s mais
est ce qu'ils étaient et terre fait
partie de ces engagements fondamentaux
fond n'a pas été abordé au départ donc
on peut considérer que ça n'en fait pas
partie aujourd'hui mais on n'est qu'au
début on va essayer de les convaincre
que c'est dans ce sens qu'il faut aller
je me semble-t-il observé que
ça faisait débat mais ça fait débat ça
fait des bars m'ont donné dans le parti
socialiste ça peut faire débat chez les
verts c'est normal toujours est il que
ça donne l'impression que le parti
socialiste est un peu le seul à réformer
à gauche ou en tout cas être investis
dans cette logique des réformes
écoutez je suis désolé que ça donne
cette impression parce que c'est pas la
réalité aujourd'hui au gouvernement il
ya le parti socialiste y aller vers il
ya les radicaux de gauche et il ya des
ministres qui représentent chacune de
ces sensibilités et il ya des débats
permanents entre les parties est
naturellement que l'action du
gouvernement est le résultat de cette
action collective pas simplement bien
sûr de l'action des ministres
socialistes avec sept abstentions
souvent des communistes voire opposition
des communistes et parfois aussi des
écologistes est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'on six mois de session
parlementaire le sénat a perdu un peu de
sa place ça dépend comment on voit les
choses
jamais la gauche n'a eu autant de
soutien au sénat au moins un an avant
chaque fois qu'on était au pouvoir et
pendant des décennies et des décennies
les choses étaient claires convenait au
sénat mais c'est dans le pays
sener voter à droite et on perdait donc
on n'avait jamais aucun soutien côté je
suis pas d'accord avec vous maintenant
qu'on a un soutien deux fois sur trois
vous trouvez que c'est scandaleux moi je
trouve que c'est un énorme progrès parce
que ça nous facilite les choses
il ya eu plus de texte voté ici par y
compris par le groupe communiste dont je
vous rappelle qu'il n'appartient pas à
la majorité gouvernementale pourquoi on
leur demanderait pourquoi on leur
demanderait de remplir des obligations
qu'ils n'ont pas souscrites et venir
voilà ils sont pas au gouvernement
ça a des inconvénients mais au moins il
ya une question de cohérence et nous on
est très sereins par rapport à cela et
on continue sur chaque texte et on
continuera à parler avec eux pour
essayer qu'il soit au rendez-vous du
vote avec le reste de la gauche mais il
n'y a aucune difficulté et ça va
beaucoup mieux que dans le sénat était
adroit en tout cas françois rebsamen qui
prétendait tout à l'heure ses voeux à la
presse eut lancé un appel à ses
partenaires de gauche justement pour
mieux faire entendre la voix 17 ans vous
êtes prêts à soutenir cet appel
bien sûr je crois qu'aujourd'hui chacun
mesure ici que parfois il n'est pas bon
pour l'institution sénatoriales ministre
des relations avec le parlement le
regrette qu'il n'y ait pas de texte voté
par par le sénat un texte est rejeté ici
on pas faire de la technique simplement
tout simplement on ne peut même pas
l'assemblée nationale reprendre tel ou
tel article qui aurait été modifié par
le sénat
telle façon qu'on peut avoir des lois
dans lesquels n'y a aucune trace du
travail souvent sérieux intéressant fait
au sénat et donc c'est assez vrai que ça
va poser un vrai problème sur pour
l'institution une dernière question
d'actualité alain vidalis bernard
arnault a transformé a transféré pendant
ses actions en belgique pour assurer la
pérennité de son groupe à ce que vous ne
trouvez pas dommage que la france ne
puisse pas assurer la continuité du
premier groupe mondial de luxe qui est
français écoutez c'est quand même c'est
pas la france que responsable c'est lui
qui a pris cette décision avec une
motivation sur laquelle il s'est pas
exprimée donc je peux pas la commenter
mais disons que c'était pour assurer la
pérennité brutale ça veut pas dire
assurer l'existence en europe ça veut
dire faire échapper ce gros pour être
très clair ce que vous reprenez cette
expression à l'impôt sur les successions
voilà ce que ça veut dire chacun chacun
appréciera mais si pour assurer la
pérennité de telle ou telle chose faut
supprimer tous les impôts sur les
successions
c'est un autre modèle de société auquel
il fait référence très bien m'écouter
merci beaucoup alain vidalis d'avoir été
un autre invité
cet après midi je vais vous laisser
rejoindre tranquillement l'hémicycle du
sénat puisque dans quelques instants va
débuter cette c'est cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
séance qui va être présidée par jean
pierre bel le président du sénat jean
marc ayrault le premier ministre sera à
présent
alors je vais vous donner la liste des
thèmes et des questions qui vont être
posées au gouvernement de cet après midi
par les sénateurs on va commencer par
une question sur les rythmes scolaires
beaucoup de questions autour de l'école
de la réforme envisagée par le ministre
de l'éducation vincent peillon et
notamment de la grève cette semaine des
enseignants à paris contre la réforme du
calendrier des rythmes scolaires donc
une question de gérard le cam qui est
communiste également une question de
catherine morin desailly qui elle est
centriste
la situation au mali et l'intervention
de la france bien sûr également être
abordée avec une question
robert urbain rue qui n'est plus
communiste qui appartient ici au sénat
au groupe des radicaux du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
henri de raincourt l'ancien ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
si nicolas sarkozy est bien lui aussi un
t'appellera le gouvernement sur cette
intervention de la france au mali
et puis parmi les thèmes également
abordés lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement cet après midi une
question sur la lutte contre la pauvreté
alors qu'une qu est ce qu une mission a
été confiée par dont 1 françois chérèque
l'ancien leader de la cfdt vous le voyez
sur ces images
jean pierre bel et jean marc ayrault se
dirige vers l'hémicycle du sénat alors
qu'on vient d'entendre la sonnerie
retentir ce qui signifie que d'un
instant à l'autre
et bien cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement va pouvoir
commencer voilà jean marc ayrault qui se
trouve à l'instant juste derrière moi
dans cette salle des conférences et la
salle qui est juste à côté de
l'hémicycle du sénat
il vient de rentrer dans l'hémicycle
sans eau pas commencé et elle se
terminera par des questions autour de la
formation professionnelle autour de la
culture scientifique et technique autour
de la pêche et enfin une dernière
question autour du projet de loi sur les
scrutins électoraux un texte important
qui va modifier non seulement le
calendrier électoral mais également les
scrutin des municipales et surtout des
cantonales à c'est un texte un projet de
loi du gouvernement qui a été rejeté la
semaine dernière par le sénat et sur
lequel bien sûr la haute assemblée sera
amené à nouveau à se pencher
voilà donc nous allons nous rendre dans
quelques instants dans l'hémicycle du
sénat la séance des questions
d'actualité comme ans on se retrouvera
ensuite ici pour refaire la différence
avec nos avions l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle et vous avez à votre
disposition pour cela des chronomètres
qu'ils sont également ma disposition je
rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que là où le ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente
la parole est à monsieur gérard le cam
pour le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est à sénateur-maire de la ruralité
qui vous pose la question monsieur le
ministre la réforme des rythmes
scolaires fait l'objet d'opposition
massive grève des enseignants du
primaire rejet des instances
consultatives et opposition de nombreux
maires les rythmes peuvent être un
élément permettant la réussite des
élèves
mais seuls ils ne peuvent lutter contre
l'échec scolaire
la réforme telle qu'elle est prévue ne
fera que déstabiliser l'école elle
manque de clarté sur ces visées ses
modalités d'application
quant aux délais de mise en oeuvre par
les communes le mois supplémentaire
accordé hier ne change rien ils sont
trop courts
ce débat a perdu de vue sa visée
éducatif pour se trouver arbitres et est
enfermé à l'aune des capacités
financières des communes qui ont la
charge sa mise en oeuvre
le rôle du scolaire et du périscolaire
n'est pas précisé des activités
pédagogiques pourront être mises en
place
mais le gouvernement ne dit pas aux
services de quel projet éducatif sa
faible durée 30 à 45 minutes en réduit
la portée et pose la question du
personnel encadrant et ce n'est
certainement pas en assouplissant les
normes d'encadrement pistes actuellement
privilégiée qu'un projet de qualité
pourra être portée au contraire cela
nuit à la sécurité des enfants sans
périmètre précis c'est de réforme va
aggraver les inégalités territoriales
face au service public de l'éducation
nationale inégalités que la droite a
amplifié depuis dix ans car si le coût
de la réforme n'est pas précisément
évalué on sait qu'il sera trop important
pour que les communes les plus pauvres
puissent y faire face
le coût réel qui revient le plus souvent
se situe autour de 150 euros par élève
comment pourront elles prendre en charge
ces nouvelles activités pédagogiques
périscolaire comment pourront elles
faire face à l'augmentation de la
demande de transport scolaire de cantine
et de centres de loisirs découlant de la
scolarité du mercredi matin
vous répondez monsieur le ministre par
une dotation exceptionnelle de 250
millions d'euros dont le montant
largement insuffisant sert davantage de
moyens
station pour une mise en oeuvre rapide
que de compensation des coûts c'était
n'est d'ailleurs attribué qu'aux seules
communes permettant en oeuvre la réforme
dès 2013
comme si l'augmentation des dépenses
était liée à la seule mise en place de
la réforme et n'était pas pérenne
il n'y a aucune urgence il faut prendre
le temps de faire une réforme au service
de la réussite de tous les élèves sur
tout le territoire
c'est pourquoi je vous demande monsieur
le ministre allez vous enfin réaffirmé
le rôle de l'état dans l'éducation
nationale en accordant une compensation
financière de la totalité des coûts aux
communes
merci merci vous répondre monsieur
vincent peillon ministre l'éducation
nationale monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur les
sénateurs vous avez raison même si c'est
un souci légitime de ne pas vouloir
enfermer comme vous le dites vous-même
la réforme de l'éducation que nous
portons priorité de ce gouvernement dans
des considérations purement financière
même si la suite de votre question était
uniquement mobilisés par cette
préoccupation nous voulons que les
enfants de france puissent tous réussir
et c'est le projet que nous avons
proposé à hier au conseil des ministres
c'est l'idée de la refondation de
l'école de la république c'est
absolument nécessaire car vous le savez
au plan national au plan européen
nous sommes en train de dégrader
profondément les résultats scolaires 25
% d'élèves en difficulté à l'entrée au
collège des inégalités qui s'accroissent
et une école qui a été ces dernières
années durement attaqué non seulement
par les restrictions de postes 80 milles
dans votre académie de rennes 3 176
postes en plus à la rentrée je vous
remercie de l'avoir noté mais en même
temps la suppression de la formation des
enseignants suppression de la formation
des enseignants ces 27 mille postes que
nous allons consacrer à redonner une
formation aux enseignants sur la
question des rythmes scolaires
tout le monde sait et j'écoutais ce
matin encore marcel rufo l'académie de
médecine les assemblées qui ont été
consultés par la précédente majorité que
l'exception française unique au monde
144 jours de classe
je fais peut-être dans l'intérêt de
beaucoup d'adultes pas dans l'intérêt
des élèves
il nous faut donc car nous avons le sens
de l'intérêt général
réagir c'est la mission que m'a confiée
le président de la république et c'est
la mission que permet de réaliser le
premier ministre hier nous avons
présenté la loi de refondation d'école
priorité aux primaires j'ai pu annoncer
7000 postes supplémentaires pour les
enseignants de cp et ce1 de nouvelles
méthodes pédagogiques
la remise en place et ce matin nous
avons signé une feuille de route
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche moi même
les recteurs et les présidents
d'université pour la formation des
enseignants est bien entendu cette
grande réforme que nous devons porter
tous ensemble qui est celle des rythmes
scolaires vous avez des inquiétudes il y
a eu des réponses un fonds de 250
millions d'euros dans la situation que
nous connaissons avec une péréquation
juste accordé par le premier ministre
pour les communes les plus en difficulté
rurales et urbaines
nous avons aussi entendu les inquiétudes
des enseignants et nous avons modifié
leurs obligations de service
je crois que si nous sommes capables de
conjuguer les uns et les autres
nos efforts nous serons capables de
réaliser cette grande réforme elle est
l'intérêt des élèves et elle est
l'intérêt de la france
merci à vous de nous accompagner merci
la parole est à monsieur robert rue pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre le 11 janvier dernier
le président de la république a pris la
courageuse décision d'engager nos forces
armées
au mali il l'a fait dans le respect de
la souveraineté de cet état à l'appel de
son président et dans le respect du
droit international en vertu d'une
résolution du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies il s'agit
incontestablement d'une rupture avec la
période que nous souhaitons désormais
révolue de la françafrique
parce que la france est liée à l'afrique
et parce qu'elle défend partout dans le
monde les valeurs de liberté
et d'humanisme elle a répondu présentes
à l'appel d'un pays ami qui aurait tout
simplement pu sombrer et devenir un état
terroriste
je veux ici rappeler avec moi mes
collègues du groupe rds à nos troupes et
à leur famille notre soutien sans
réserve ce qui se joue en ce moment au
mali c'est la sécurité de ce pays c'est
celle d'une partie du continent africain
mais aussi celle de l'europe l'europe
justement alors que nous venons de
célébrer le 50e anniversaire du traité
d'amitié franco-allemande l'union
européenne dans son ensemble se
montre-t-elle suffisamment présentes à
ce rendez vous majeur
si les aides matérielles et logistiques
commencent à arriver
il apparaît en effet dans l'opinion
publique qu'aux côtés de la france la
réponse européenne n'est pas
suffisamment à la hauteur des enjeux que
représente la stabilité et le
développement de l'afrique pour le
destin de nos deux continents
à ce titre et parce que au bruit des
armes doit succéder celui de la
reconstruction et de la paix et le plus
tôt sera le mieux
l'europe devra enfin prendre ses
responsabilités envers ce continent
à bien des égards rongé par une terrible
pauvreté qui sert on le sait le terreau
au terrorisme et aux extrémistes les
plus violents alors monsieur le premier
ministre
pouvez vous informer le sénat des
dernières évolutions de la situation
militaire au mali de la mise en place de
la misma et de notre coopération avec
l'algérie
quelles sont les nouvelles dispositions
que vous vous prêtez à prendre vous
apprêtez à prendre pour inciter nos
partenaires européens a engagé un
partenariat de type nouveau avec
l'afrique et par ailleurs enfin que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur les intentions
de la france en faveur d'une politique
d' aide au développement
une politique concrète permettant de
stabiliser cette région de consolider la
démocratie et surtout surtout de lutter
à la source contre la misère et la
pauvreté
merci
la parole est à monsieur jean marc
ayrault premier ministre merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur robert
hue
vous avez décrit avec beaucoup de
précision la situation telle qu'elle se
présente aujourd'hui au mali
et vous avez raison de rappeler que la
décision du président de la république
d'engager nos forces au mali est une
décision grave
mais en même temps à la fois courageuse
et nécessaire
c'est vrai que le 20 décembre le conseil
de sécurité a adopté une résolution à
l'unanimité il faut le rappeler et qui
prévoit la mise en place d'une force
africaine une force militaire africaine
la misma mais qui le 11 janvier force
est de constater n'était pas en mesure
d'arrêter ce qui était en train de se
passer
je crois qu'il faut bien à mesurer ce
qui s'est passé en effet nous avons été
informés de ce que les groupes
terroristes et différentes factions
terroristes étaient en train
d'entreprendre voyant se préparer la
mise en place de cette force africaine
eh bien ils avaient décidé de pénétrer
beaucoup plus loin dans le territoire
malien est de déstabiliser totalement ce
pays et de lui enlever toute sa
souveraineté
parfois certains ont confondu les deux
temps pourquoi d'un côté une résolution
et d'autres l'autre côté l'intervention
de la france
la france n'a pas prétendu se substituer
à ce qui doit se faire et qui est en
train de se faire
aujourd'hui la la mise en place de cette
force multinationale africaine est en
train de se préparer
l'état major est à bamako les premières
troupes arrivent et à la fin du mois de
janvier je crois que plusieurs milliers
de soldats est en tout cas mi-février de
différents pays africains de la cedeao
mais aussi de membres qui n'en sont pas
je pense au tchad seront sur place et en
état de fonctionner par ailleurs l'union
européenne que vous avez mentionné a
décidé spontanément d'apporter son
soutien matériel à la france à travers
différentes décisions de plusieurs états
de l'union européenne mais surtout
d'accélérer la mise en place de l'unité
de formation de non seulement de l'armée
malienne mais aussi de cette force
internationale l'état major est
également sur place
donc c'est tout ce ce processus qui est
en train de se mettre en place mais qui
a quand même conduit la france et le
président de la république à prendre la
décision d'engager nos soldats le 11
janvier
c'est pas une situation décision facile
je les dis le conseil de défense a été
éclairée et c'est cette décision qu'a
pris le président de la république
pourquoi si nous n'étions pas intervenus
la mise en oeuvre de la résolution du 20
décembre n'aurait et aurait été
impossible et le mali serait aujourd'hui
un état totalement en main dans les
mains des terroristes est au coeur de
l'afrique au coeur du mali mais au coeur
de l'afrique de l'ouest
c'est toute cette partie qui serait
aujourd'hui déstabilisé avec les menaces
non seulement sur l'indépendance du mali
mais sur la stabilité de l'afrique de
l'ouest est aussi sûr l'europe et sur la
france ne nous y trompons pas donc le
chef de l'état par intérim du mali le
président traoré a appelé le président
de la république au secours et a fait
une demande officielle de soutien de la
france la france a consulté tous ses
partenaires
d'abord les partenaires africains qui
ont tous à l'unanimité et ils l'ont
confirmé encore samedi dernier à la
réunion d'abidjan à laquelle la france
était représentée par le ministre des
affaires étrangères laurent fabius
ils ont tous affirmé leur soutien mais
aussi leur reconnaissance à la france
car aujourd'hui
eh bien ça serait même plus parle la
peine de parler de la misma donc cet
objectif d'arrêter la progression des
groupes terroristes est atteint
nos troupes avec les troupes maliennes
sont déjà en train de progresser mais la
france n'a pas vocation j'ai déjeuné
déjà dit hier à l'assemblée nationale à
rester au nord-mali c'est la force
africaine qui doit la supplée le plus
rapidement possible et c'est en train de
se préparer
mais au-delà de cela il faudra réussir
aussi la transition politique
le som avec des institutions provisoires
les dirigeants provisoires au mali
transitoire et donc il est très
important et la france avec la
communauté internationale le conseil de
sécurité doit y veiller attentivement
que cette transition politique soit
réussie ce n'est pas facile à faire
il faudra bien sûr exclure dans les
discussions les groupes terroristes
mais parler avec les différentes
composantes de la communauté nationale
malienne des forces politiques mais
aussi à prendre en compte les
spécificités territoriales
je pense aussi au nord-mali aux touareg
donc ce travail il faut langage et le
plus vite possible et surtout contribué
à sa réussite et puis il ya un autre
volet vous avez parfaitement eu raison
d'aborder et qui est le volet du
développement
nous sommes là dans des pays
particulièrement pauvre en tout cas la
plupart d'entre eux sont
particulièrement pauvres et donc c'est
la responsabilité non seulement de la
france mais c'est aussi celle de
l'europe de tout faire pour assurer le
développement du continent africain et
tout particulièrement de l'afrique de
l'ouest
le ministre du développement pascal
canfin est en train de préparer des
assises du développement et qui se
tiendront donc dans les prochains mois
et j'espère qu'elles contribueront aussi
à mobiliser l'ensemble de nos
partenaires européens tout cas c'est une
conviction de la france le président de
la république françois hollande dans son
discours de dakar a rappelé cette
nécessité
et je crois que c'est notre
responsabilité d'être en première ligne
vous avez rappelé un passé révolu celui
de la françafrique c'est bien loin en
tout cas ce n'est pas dans nos
conceptions mais ça veut pas dire qu'on
doit et vous l'avez parfaitement bien
dit monsieur le sénateur robert hue
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant que la
france doit se désintéresser de
l'afrique
et ce n'est pas seulement la
responsabilité de la france c'est la
responsabilité de toute l'europe le
continent africain
un bel avenir devant lui qui passe par
la démocratie qui passe par des
institutions stables mais qui passe
aussi par le développement et ce
développement sera celui de l'afrique un
développement durable un développement
qui donne des perspectives à tous les
peuples africains mais qui sont aussi le
nôtre c'est à la fois l'intérêt des
africains c'est ainsi la plainte est ré
des français et des européens donc
soyons à la hauteur de l'île
thouars et pour conclure je voudrais et
je suis sûr que vous y fassiez zouzou
seraient ils seraient sensibles
également mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs s'est adressé à nos soldats
un message de solidarité de soutien dans
la mission difficile qui est la leur au
service de la paix et de la liberté
merci monsieur henri de raincourt mon le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères et concerne également le mali
je sais que monsieur fabius n'est pas là
parce qu'en ce moment même il est en
train d'accueillir à l'occasion de ce
retour sur le sur le sol national
notre compatriote madame florence cassez
et comme chacun ici je mesure les
sentiments qu'elle doit éprouver en cet
instant où elle retrouve la mère patrie
et tous nous sommes heureux très heureux
de voir que ces années de souffrance et
de martyrs
aujourd'hui sont derrière elle et donc
il est tout à fait normal que le
ministre des affaires étrangères soit à
l'aéroport pour l'accueillir
alors ma question s'adresse au ministre
des affaires européennes et ça tombe
d'ailleurs aussi très bien compte tenu
de la nature de ma question qui prolonge
parfaitement ce que vient de dire à
l'instant le premier ministre je veux
rappeler quand même que le président de
la république à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse tenue le 13
novembre dernier avait indiqué qu'en
aucun cas la france n'interviendrait
elle-même au mali et devant la tournure
des événements comme cela vient d'être
rappelée à l'appel des autorités
fusse-t-elle provisoire de ce pays dans
le respect absolu des décisions du
conseil de sécurité le président de la
république a pris la sage et responsable
décision d'engager la france directement
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme le
11 janvier vous savez que nous avons
approuvé cette décision du président de
la république
nous soutenons cette action des pouvoirs
publics du gouvernement de nos soldats à
qui nous aussi nous voulons
naturellement rendre hommage alors
monsieur le ministre lors de vos
échanges avec les partenaires européens
vos homologues ont salué de façon
unanime l'action de la france et c'est
très bien
lorsque j'entends madame ashton dire
l'union européenne va jouer un rôle clé
est actif dans les semaines à venir
c'est positif mais nous voudrions des
choses concrètes qu'ils aillent excusez
moi monsieur le premier ministre
un peu au delà à des actions de
formation dans lesquels l'europe est
engagée
l'europe a élaboré la stratégie pour le
sel pour le développement du sahel et
nous avons un immense besoin dans cette
bataille très difficile à livrer contre
le terrorisme de l'europe de l'union
européenne n'ont pas pays par pays
mais globalement alors monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le ministre
des affaires européennes pouvez vous
nous dire aujourd'hui quelles sont les
efforts qui sont engagées par le
gouvernement français et quelles sont
les perspectives en matière
d'affirmation de la présence de l'union
européenne d'une manière claire et
précise dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
merci monsieur bernard cazeneuve
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
monsieur sellette à merci beaucoup pour
votre question qui est l'occasion de
préciser quel est le rôle de l'union
européenne dans la crise du mali et de
préciser aussi les conditions dans
lesquelles notre pays a été amenée avec
ses partenaires de l'union européenne à
définir pour le mali une stratégie qui
permette à ce pays de retrouver son
intégrité territoriale de faire face aux
risques terroristes et par delà le mal
il s'agissait de sécuriser le continent
afrique a lui-même qui risquait en cas
de contamination terrorise de se trouver
déstabilisés est assurée aussi
la sécurité de l'europe et de notre
propre pays le premier point sur lequel
je voudrais insister comme l'a fait le
premier ministre à l'instant c'est sur
le rôle qu'a joué l'union européenne
dans la préparation de la formation des
troupes maliennes afin que celle ci
puisse permettre au mali de retrouver
son intégrité territoriale
vous avez eu raison d'insister monsieur
le sénateur sur le fait que l'ensemble
des événements qui se sont produits le
wali sont intervenus dans le strict
cadre de la légalité internationale et
ce fut d'ailleurs là la première action
concrète de l'union européenne il n'y
aurait pas eu la prise des résolutions
20 56 20 71 20 85 qui ont défini le
cadre légal dans lequel nous sommes
intervenus s'il n'y avait pas eu de la
part de l'union européenne au sein des
nations unies
une intervention conjointe convergent de
tous ces pays qui permettait la
définition de ce cadre international
deuxièmement nous avons souhaité que
tous les pays de l'union européenne
puissent définir ensemble les modalités
d'une formation des troupes maliennes de
l'armée malienne pour permettre à
celle-ci d'assurer la sécurité sur le
territoire du mali et pour permettre
aussi comme l'indiqué monsieur le
premier ministre à la misma de pouvoir
avec des troupes en nombre
assurer durablement la sécurité du mali
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
avec les pays de l'union européenne à
travers la mise en place d'un dispositif
de formation intitulé you thème décidé
de mobiliser près de 500 militaires
venus de toute l'europe pour assurer la
formation et par ailleurs nous avons
également indiqué que nous étions à la
disposition de la cedeao pour assurer
aux côtés de la misma toute mission qui
permettait cette formation si au moment
où les terroristes ont décidé de faire
mouvement
la france n'avait pas sous l'impulsion
du président de la république pris la
décision d'intervenir tout ce que nous
avons décidé avec les européens ne
serait pas possible aujourd'hui le mali
serait tombé entre les mains des
terroristes est aujourd'hui la situation
soit celles d'une déstabilisation
majeure
et nous avons par conséquent continuer à
travailler avec les européens qui
contrairement à ce que nous avons pu
entendre à certains moments ont mobilisé
des moyens à nos côtés moyens aériens
pour assurer du transport de troupes et
en nombre moyens sanitaires pour venir
en assistance moyens humanitaires qui
seront bien nécessaire sur le terrain et
par ailleurs nous réunissons la
conférence des donateurs à abidjan à
addis abeba le 29 pour mobiliser des
moyens financiers qui permettront
d'aller au bout de cette opération
nous sommes donc dans une action se
rebelle où la france joue un rôle de
précurseur pour rétablir l'intégrité
territoriale du mali et assurer la
sécurité du sahel face aux risques
terroristes
merci la parole est à présent madame
catherine morin desailly pour le groupe
union des démocrates et indépendants us
et dans monsieur le ministre chers
collègues d'ici fin mars
les communes de nos départements sont
appelés à se prononcer sur une réforme
des rythmes scolaires applicable en 2013
ou 2014 pour laquelle les élus n'ont été
ni sérieusement informer encore moins
consultés aujourd'hui ce projet aux
contours flous dont l'impact financier
n'a absolument pas été évaluées a été
sévèrement retoquée par toutes les
instances de concertation comités
techniques ministériels conseil
supérieur de l'éducation commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes
aujourd'hui dans un contexte de baisse
annoncé des dotations de l'état pour
2014 et 2015
les élus se sont pris à la gorge et
s'interroge sur la faisabilité du projet
en l'état
que se passera-t-il lorsque c'est aide
exceptionnelle de 250 millions d'euros
promise pour 2013 disparaîtra est qui
selon les premières estimations de nos
collègues apparaît déjà très en deçà des
dépenses engendrées
sous quelles responsabilités seront
placés les enfants entre 15h30 et 16h30
qui les encadrera aura-t-on partout en
ville comme en milieu rural les moyens
de recruter des personnels qualifiés
pour les activités culturelles ou
sportives annoncé des questions toutes
simples monsieur le ministre
d'élus qui nous interpelle tous les
jours
pour des questions auxquelles vous
n'avez pas franchement répondu tout à
l'heure savez-vous réellement ce qu'est
gérer une petite commune et son école ou
encore un regroupement scolaire en
milieu rural ces élus qui font beaucoup
d'efforts déjà revendique tout autant
que vous le bien-être et l'intérêt de
l'enfant
aussi après on til ce qu'il risque de
creuser des inégalités entre les
territoires
les sénateurs eu dix pensent que
l'éducation est une priorité aussi
monsieur le ministre nous voulons vous
alerter contre un passage en force qui
risque d'être contre-productif pour un
aménagement nécessaire du temps de
l'école car tel était bien les
conclusions de la conférence nationale
sur les rythmes scolaires
initiée par luc chatel au sein de
laquelle j'ai travaillé d'ailleurs avec
deux autres sénateurs de groupes
politiques différents dans nos
recommandations qui par ailleurs
proposer un projet plus global
j'ai intégré aussi le rythme de l'année
ce que je ne dois pas vraiment dans le
projet nous insistions sur la méthode
une méthode qui devait privilégier la
concertation à la précipitation qui a
été la vôtre depuis le début et contre
laquelle le premier ministre vous a
d'ailleurs mis en garde
en juin dernier notre groupe pense qu'il
faut privilégier l'expérimentation la
souplesse qui permet aussi tout en
respectant les objectifs d adaptation en
clair monsieur le ministre pour réformer
vous devez changer avec l'ensemble des
partenaires de l'école
en premier lieu avec les représentants
des collectivités qui assumons la mise
en oeuvre aujourd'hui cgc élus dont nous
nous faisons le porte parole vous
demande des moyens pour appliquer cette
réforme mais surtout du temps et ce
n'est pas le mois de réflexion
supplémentaire accordé aux communes qui
méritera de résoudre le problème car
aujourd'hui il faut bien le dire c'est
la plus grande des confusion qui règne
merci la parole et plats monsieur
vincent peillon ministre l'éducation
nationale madame la sénatrice vous avait
opportunément rappelé que vous aviez
fait partie du comité de pilotage d'une
grande consultation nationale sur la
réforme des rythmes scolaires menée par
mon prédécesseur pendant plusieurs mois
cette consultation a tiré le bilan de ce
qui avait été une des réformes les plus
tristes mise en oeuvre par la majorité
précédente
la suppression des quatre jours et demi
vous avez vous même tiré la conclusion
qu'il fallait revenir à quatre jours et
demi de classe 5 heures si on le pouvait
par jour et vous avez même fait la
préconisation de rajouter deux semaines
de cours et puis vous êtes arrêté là
c'est dommage parce que vous l'avez
reconnue vous même c'est l'intérêt des
élèves dans la situation que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure que nous soyons
capables tous ensemble de réaliser cette
réforme il faut la concertation elle a
duré plus d'un an
à votre époque elle a duré plusieurs
mois depuis notre installation toutes
les associations de maires ont été reçus
à plusieurs reprises y compris les
maires de zones montagneuses les maires
ruraux qui sont prononcés pour
hélas m f mais je vois que vos
informations ne sont pas toujours justes
vous avez parlé du la commission des
normes où les élus sont représentés elle
a validé hier ce projet de décret par
lui voix pour et deux voix contre
pourquoi parce que les informations leur
sont enfin parvenus qui jusque là avait
du mal à passer
étant donné le travail de désinformation
que vous faites après pourtant
l'affichage du souci c'est dommage
c'est dommage parce que pour des raisons
purement politiciennes
vous prenez les enfants de france en
otage on a vu d'ailleurs on a vu
d'ailleurs qu'elle était à l'égard de
l'éducation nationale vaut pratiquer
pendant cinq ans et nous sommes obligés
aujourd'hui d'effectuer une réparation
c'est vrai sur les rythmes car c'est
vous qui avait fait la semaine de quatre
jours
unique au monde c'est vrai sur les
remplacements car vous avez supprimé 80
mille postes c'est vrai sur la formation
des enseignants
car vous l'avez supprimés eh bien nous
nous pensons à l'avenir de la france
nous apportons des réponses concrètes
sur les taux d'encadrement sur le
financement de cette réforme sur la
consultation des uns et des autres et si
vous avez encore des inquiétudes au delà
de celles que vous entretenez pour des
raisons politiciennes
mes services sont entièrement à votre
disposition pour vous permettre de faire
ces projets territoriaux dans lesquelles
les élus locaux ont une responsabilité
particulière
certains ne veulent pas je vois le maire
de marseille accordée à l'école la
priorité qu'elle mérite
l'état français le veut l'école veut
mettez vous un mouvement merci merci
monsieur martial bourquin pour le groupe
socialiste apparentés
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez fait de la lutte
contre la pauvreté une priorité
gouvernementale
sachez que vous avez notre soutien le
plus total pour redonner dignité à ces
millions de personnes
la précarité dans notre pays est le fait
d'une crise extrêmement violente et d'un
chômage de masse inacceptable
mais c'est aussi le résultat de
décisions politiques prises par les
gouvernements précédents
parmi ces décisions une est
particulièrement inique
c'est celle qui concerne les potentiels
bénéficiaires de l'allocation équivalent
retraite qui ont quitté leur emploi
avant le 1er janvier 2009 les classes
d'âge 1952 1953
souvenons nous en 2008 des dizaines de
milliers de personnes
ou accepter des plans sociaux au terme
de quarante années de travail en pensant
et de protégé par la 1ère leur employeur
l'administration leur avait promis le
gouvernement fillon en eau sont non
seulement mis fin à cette allocation au
1er janvier 2009 mais a prolongé leur
supplice de deux ans en les ignorant
totalement lors de la réforme des
retraites pour 2010 ils ont été méprisés
ils ont été jetés dans la précarité et
la pauvreté
au sénat nous avons à deux reprises
obtenu la prolongation de cette
disposition lors de la loi de finances
2013 dont on fait voter avec l'ensemble
des groupes de la majorité une
contribution exceptionnelle de
solidarité pour prendre en compte la
situation de ces classes d'âge une
délégation formée de moi même ronan
kerdraon ana neri s'est rendu à matignon
où nous avons reçu une écoute de qualité
je sais aussi que les principales
centrales syndicales nous ont très
récemment encore alerté sur la situation
de ces personnes monsieur le premier
ministre je connais
votre attachement la justice sociale je
veux vous sensibiliser sur le drame
humain que vit au quotidien ces
personnes elles vivre un vrai calvaire
ma question est simple allez-vous
réparer les erreurs des précédents
gouvernements fillon et 17 classes d'âge
qui vit dans le dénuement la précarité
et la plus complète
elles ont travaillé si longtemps ces
femmes et ces hommes ils ont trahi si
longtemps ils ont le droit de retrouver
la dignité
ils ont deux le droit de retrouver
l'espoir que jean marc ayrault au
premier ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur martial
bourquin d'abord merci de votre soutien
au plan du gouvernement de lutte contre
la pauvreté et pour l'inclusion sociale
j'aimerais bien que mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qui ironisait
que vous puissiez aussi vous engager
dans le soutien à la lutte contre les
injustices
il ya neuf millions de personnes
aujourd'hui qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté en france
ça mérite bien quand même un combat une
mobilisation générale
et là vous soulignez une situation qui
est particulièrement injuste parce qu en
quelque sorte il ya tromperie
parce que vous faites allusion à trop de
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui sur le
carreau qui sont des salariés qui ont
perdu leur emploi ou qui avait accepté
de bonne foi un départ volontaire en
2009 et 2010 et qui pensaient pouvoir
bénéficier de l'allocation équivalent
retraite
et puis vous l'avez rappelé le précédent
gouvernement fermé la porte et l'a fait
il a fermé la porte au moment où il
était plus difficile pour les salariés
d'atteindre l'âge légal à la retraite
puisque dans le même temps la réforme de
retraites de 2010 a augmenté cette durée
légale et ce qui fait que les personnes
concernées par la mère née entre 52 et
53 se sont trouvés doublement pénalisés
et aujourd'hui le gouvernement précédent
a mis en place une catastrophe une
allocation transitoire qui s'appelle la
ts qui est versé soit un ensemble de
conditions tellement draconien
en réalité ce sont quelques certaines
centaines de personnes qui peuvent en
bénéficier c'est à dire que le problème
reste entier et vous faites partie de
ceux avec le président de votre groupe
françois rebsamen qui m'avait alerté il
ya déjà plusieurs semaines et qui est
particulièrement mobilisée comme ce
leçons et vous l'avez à juste titre
rappelé toutes les organisations
syndicales représentatives des salariés
eh bien vous avez raison il faut
solutionner ce problème il faut
supprimer cette injustice et le
gouvernement s'y est engagé devant votre
assemblée le 26 novembre dernier au
moment de la discussion de la loi de
finances pour 2013 ou à cette occasion
vous et vos collègues vous avez fait une
analyse précise de la situation
cette analyse nous rappelle que plus
d'une dizaine de milliers de personnes
nées entre 1952 1953 et qui n'ont
toujours pas atteint
je viens de le rappeler l'âge légal de
la retraite à taux plein vivent
actuellement avec le revenu de
solidarité active ou l'allocation
spécifique de solidarité
mais ce sont des personnes qui vivent
douloureusement cette situation qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie qui ont toutes
leurs annuités et qui n'ont que quelques
mois voire parfois un an maximum à
attendre avant de liquider leur retraite
et qui sont au rsa alors nous allons
régler ce problème
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
répondre à l'urgence sociale que vous
avez rappelé j'ai décidé à titre
dérogatoire de mettre en place une
prestation d'un montant équivalent à la
rue à la 1ère pour en bénéficier tous
les chômeurs ayant de faibles ressources
âgés de 59 et de 60 ans inscrits à pôle
emploi avant le 31 décembre 2010 et qui
n'ont pas pu demander la 1ère cette
prestation complètera leur revenu pour
le porter à 1030 euros par mois et pour
ça nous allons prendre un décret simple
et qui permettra l'ouverture de ce droit
à partir du 1er mars 2013 c'est à dire
dans quelques semaines désormais
ainsi la justice pourra être rétabli en
permettant à ces personnes d'attendre
l'âge de la retraite à taux plein dans
la dignité et la solidarité nationale je
vous rappelle que cette mesure vient
compléter une autre décision que le
gouvernement a pris après l'élection
présidentielle et conformément aux
engagements du président de la
république le 2 juillet 2012
il a en effet ouvert un droit de départ
à taux plein pour les personnes ayant
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans et
disposant encore là encore de leurs
annuités
ce sont ces salariés âgés de 60 ans et
qui ayant largement dépassé les annuités
nécessaires étaient injustement
pénalisés nous avons voulu donner un
signe fort qui ne règle pas bien entendu
l'avenir du financement notre système de
retraite de ces injustices de ces
problèmes de financement mais qui donne
le sens de l'action du gouvernement qui
donne le temps et qui donne la direction
et qui éclaire sur le souci à la fois de
prendre à bras le corps les problèmes
économiques et financiers mais de
toujours marquer nos décisions du sceau
de la justice merci la parole est à
madame marie-christine blandin pour le
groupe écologiste
merci ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
madame la ministre une large
concertation a eu lieu dans le cadre des
assises que vous avez organisée
réunissant enseignants et chercheurs
c'est nécessaire mais non suffisant et
le risque existe d'une focalisation sur
la seule innovation technologique votre
loi pourra s'inscrire dans une réflexion
plus globale sur science et société
en quoi la science participait le
développement de société plus solidaire
plus responsable en quoi répond elle aux
incertitudes des citoyens il en va de la
connaissance
il en va aussi de l'emploi plus de 50%
des ans
en france et même des secteurs non
marchands et associatif ce que l'on
appelait diffusion de la culture
scientifique technique et industrielle
repose et il y a trente ans sur une
véritable ambition avec des moyens puis
le concept s'est qualifiée sous le nom
de partage de la culture scientifique
éloignant la caricature de quelques
rares sachant devant un peuple inculte
et à convaincre
et puis les budgets se sont fait rares
en 2010 une gouvernance aventureuse à
démanteler l'action ministérielle en
externalisant la gestion des moyens de
toute la france auprès d'un seul
établissement parisien
universcience imaginerait on confier
tout le budget des théâtres de france à
l'odéon
charge à lui de le répartir les
associations licencie la probable
décentralisation des cci auprès des
régions ne répondra pas à l'ensemble de
la question
pourtant des initiatives remarquables
nous donne des horizons séduisant des
recherches participatif dans le
programme est définie par une
institution comme le muséum des sciences
citoyennes dont la recherche est défini
avec des associations des sciences
coopérative dont le programme éco
construit codé fini co piloté comme
cette recherche sur les céréales
panifiables en ile-de-france avec l'inra
les associations les boulangers les
paysans et les consommateurs
quelle part madame la ministre allez
vous donner dans votre projet de loi à
ces pistes indispensable pour une
société de la connaissance participative
de l'intelligence collective et
résistante aux obscurantismes madame
geneviève fioraso ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice marie christine
blandin la diffusion de la culture
scientifique et technique vous l'avez
dit est un enjeu essentiel de la
politique je souhaite mener car lé
fondement même d'une société
démocratique et de la connaissance
partagée la science appartient tous et
nous devons créer les conditions pour
que toutes et tous puissent s'approprier
les principes et les méthodes de la
connaissance scientifique dans toutes
ses acceptions des sciences humaines et
sociales jusqu'aux sciences dites
exactes
et puis s'approprier également la
culture d'innovation et de création
l'audace l'envi d'entreprendre ans le
renouveau du débat public entre science
et société est une exigence politique
c'est vrai qu'il doit faire l'objet d'un
programme spécifique avec l'appui des
recherches en sciences humaines et
sociales
cette démarche commence avec une
définition claire des enjeux et de la
stratégie nationale de la recherche
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
cette stratégie que nous sommes en train
de finaliser en partenariat sera basé
sur des défis sociétaux lisible pour
tous et par tous renvoyant l'expérience
et aux interrogations quotidiennes sur
la santé l'énergie le changement
climatique
l'innovation le numérique la sécurité
alimentaire parce que les scientifiques
doivent se faire comprendre de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
toutes ces dimensions de la
démocratisation de la culture 106
scientifiques et techniques feront donc
partie intégrante de l'agenda national
de la stratégie de la recherche que nous
sommes en train de construire au sein de
mon ministère et qui répondent à ces
défis sociétaux comme le fait d'ailleurs
le programme européen le programme
européen de recherche horizon 20
le principe même de cet agenda ainsi que
ses grandes orientations seront inscrits
dans la loi tout comme la mission de
service public d'enseignement supérieur
et de recherche en matière de culture
scientifique et technique au ministère
et le ministère de la culture et la
communication coordonne coordonneront
sous une forme en cours de définition
l'action gouvernementale avec d'autres
ministères le ministère de l'éducation
nationale en premier lieu
mais aussi ministère de l'écologie du
redressement productif l'acte iii de la
décentralisation vous l'avez évoqué
devrait être attribué aux conseils
régionaux des compétences nouvelles en
matière de culture scientifique et
technique et de leur diffusion
ils devraient coordonner les réseaux
territoriaux sous cette impulsion
pourront se constituer de véritables
projets territoriaux en généralisant les
nombreuses initiatives qui ont été
prises je pensais celles qui ont été
prises par les prix nobel de gênes et et
charpak avec la main à la pâte et les
petits débrouillards dans le programme
des investissements d'avenir
près de 200 millions d'euros sont
consacrés au programme de culture
scientifique et technique
ils sont destinés au public scolaire dès
le plus jeune âge avec une large
diffusion site web radio la formation
des enseignants dans les écoles
supérieures du professorat et de
l'éducation prendre en compte ces enjeux
en s'appuyant sur les ressources
territoriales que j'ai évoqués nous
l'enverrons d'ailleurs discuté ce matin
avec les présidents d'universités les
recteurs qui vont accueillir ces écoles
enfin les regroupements territoriaux les
communautés d'université sont ramenés à
proposer systématiquement une stratégie
de diffusion de la culture scientifique
qui sera évaluée à intégrer je conclurai
avec cette phrase de marie curie que je
souhaiterais partager avec vous rien
n'est à craindre tout est à comprendre
merci la parole est à monsieur jean
claude carle pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la réforme des rythmes
scolaires catalyse tous les
mécontentements
les enseignants étaient dans la rue ce
mardi à paris 90% étaient en grève n'en
déplaise à monsieur bruno julliard qui
trouve désormais que certains syndicats
utilisent beaucoup trop leur capacité de
blocage
les parents craignent pour les activités
périscolaires les élus qui devront payer
les surcoûts n'ont pas été associés
président gaudin l'a rappelé plus de 15
millions d'euros pour la seule ville de
marseille pour calais à l'autre bout de
la france
ville dans notre collègue natacha
bouchart et mer se sera 1,5 million
d'euros pour mobiliser 700 agents et un
million d'euros pour le seul surcoût de
transport dans mon propre département
et pourtant monsieur le ministre cette
réforme est nécessaire la france à
l'année scolaire la plus
courte la semaine également la plus
courte et la journée la plus longue
alors pourquoi la seule réduction d'une
petite demi-heure journalières
provoque-t-elle temps protestations
alors que chacun reconnaît cependant que
la situation n'est pas satisfaisante
deux raisons majeures l'une de fond
l'autre de méthode la raison de fond
celle approche trop dogmatique de
chronobiologistes en ce qui concerne le
calendrier scolaire par exemple ne tenir
compte que du fameux 7 2 est une erreur
si l'on n'intègre pas les rythmes
économique et les rythmes climatique
dans une région comme la mienne le
décalage en mai d'une semaine de
vacances de printemps
c'est 10 % de recettes en moins pour le
secteur touristique 10% qui pouvaient
participer au financement des surcoûts
engendrés par la réforme raison de
méthodes monsieur le ministre il est
illusoire dans ce domaine comme dans
d'autres de vouloir imposer le même
rythme à toute la france depuis la rue
de grenelle
cela ne marche pas notre mission
d'information l'a clairement constater
il y un an
seules les réformes basée sur le
partenariat et la proximité donne des
résultats
alors monsieur le ministre allez-vous
suspendre ce décret qui traîne
d'ailleurs à être publiées donné des
directives aux recteurs et aux
directeurs académique pour qu'ils
engagent une réelle contractualisation
avec les collectivités les halles coeur
locaux de la communauté l'aide éducative
dans un cadre de partenariat gagnant
gagnant
le premier ministre est allé dans le
sens de cette demande hier après-midi en
vous invitant à prolonger la
concertation jusqu'à la fin mars
preuve monsieur le ministre qu'il y en
avait pas eu ou pas suffisamment rue je
doute cependant que ce temps soit
suffisant merci monsieur vincent clients
ministres éducation nationale
très chers sénateurs on va avoir
l'occasion la de vérifier que nous
allons bien dans le sens que vous
souhaitez en effet que dit le décret qui
sera publié vendredi
c'est que la consultation des conseils
d'école et la consultation des élus doit
permettre à l'éducation nationale la
consultation de contractualiser des
plans territoriaux éducatif
d'aménagement des rythmes scolaires qui
seront bien différents comme vous le
souhaiter évidemment selon les communes
et les projets éducatifs
vous avez un souci des lunes montagne je
comprends et c'est pour ça que j'ai reçu
à plusieurs reprises les une montagne et
que j'ai donnée et le premier ministre
lui-même raison alors de mordre
c'est la première fois que dans une
politique publique vous avez une
péréquation de cette nature
vous avez 50 euros universel mais 90
euros pour les communes éligibles un
déçu ou à la dsr et en particulier les
communes rurales
c'est près du triple et ça fait donc
quelques moyens vous avez demandé en
même temps qu'il puisse y avoir un
certain nombre des dérogations mais sur
des bases que vous devez quand même
essayer de comprendre et transmettent
justement un peu d'arithmétique
si nous rajoutons trois heures le
mercredi matin
nous enlevons pas une demi heure quatre
jours ça ferait deux heures il y aurait
une heure qui se baladent ces trois
quarts d'heure le des crédits de murs
maximum pour vous permettre d'organiser
au mieux selon vos moyens
les journées scolaires certains
choisissent la pause méridienne
d'autres veulent faire davantage le soir
certaines villes déjà qu'ils sont aux
quatre jours et demi
choisissent de groupe et sur d après
midi entière les activités péri
éducatives
nous avons concilier un certain nombre
de cadres nationaux
c'est quand même le minimum avec
précisément la possibilité pour vous
tous de faire au mieux dans l'intérêt
des élèves
vous savez cette réforme vous le dites
vous même il faut la faire
elle n'a pas été fait pourquoi parce
qu'elle est difficile elle suppose pour
les enseignants pour les professeurs
pour les parents peut-être pour nous
tous un certain effort et vous savez je
le rappelais ce matin la grande
tradition
on française ce qui est facile n'a pas
tellement d'intérêt
là où nous serons jugés c'est notre
capacité de résoudre un certain nombre
de difficultés
ce dont nous parlons aujourd'hui c'est
la capacité de nos enfants des élèves
français de réussir tous les enfants et
c'est l'avenir de la france
nous étions en allemagne à deux jours 25
% de jeunes français qui sont au chômage
il ya des pays ces 10 %
ce décrochage est liée aux difficultés
de notre système scolaire
elles ont été accrues ces dernières
années je crois vraiment qu'on peut tous
se rassembler et peut-être se dépasser
s'élever à notre tour comme les élèves
dans l'intérêt et dans la cause de la
réussite scolaire de tous les enfants de
la république
nous comptons sur vous nous avons
entendu les élus nous les accompagnerons
et j'ai donnée à l'éducation nationale
un certain nombre de consignes pour
aider les mères à construire leur projet
il faut vraiment que nous fassions cette
réforme
merci la parole est un monsieur claude
jeannerot pour le socialiste et
apparentés mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué en charge de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
les français qui nous regardent
connaissent bien l'afpa l'association
professionnelle des adultes ils la
connaissent bien parce qu'elle est
présente dans tous nos territoires
départementaux
ils la connaissent bien surtout parce
qu'ils savent que depuis sa création il
y a plus de 60 ans elle a permis à plus
de 5 millions de travailleurs chômeurs
ou salariés de se former d'obtenir un
diplôme et un savoir faire professionnel
pour beaucoup d'entre elles a représenté
une véritable seconde chance
elle a aussi permis aux entreprises de
notre pays de recruter les salariés
qualifiés nécessaires dans cette période
de chômage massif
plus que jamais nous avons besoin de
disposer d'organismes de formation
efficace permettant de préparer les
qualifications attendues
or depuis des années force est de le
constater l'état s'est désengagé
financièrement de cette institution une
vision libérale a voulu en faire un
organisme de formation comme les autres
pourtant la réponse aux besoins de
formation
nous le savons bien dans une logique
d'intérêt public ne saurait être soumise
aux seules règles du marché
ainsi jeté dans le bain de la
concurrence intégral l'afpa il y a
quelques semaines était menacée de
disparition
dès votre arrivée au gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
messieurs les ministres vous avez su
prendre les premières mesures d'urgence
surtout le premier ministre a rendu
public la semaine dernière à caen les
décisions prises en faveur de l'afpa
pour assurer son sauvetage
mais au delà il est nécessaire désormais
d'assurer l'action de lave pas sur la
durée en confortant sa mission de
service public tout en lui permettant
bien sûr d'évoluer et de se moderniser
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
apporter au 9300 salariés de
l'institution et au delà aux cent
cinquante mille stagiaires accueillis
chaque année un éclairage sur la
stratégie de pérennisation de l'afpa tel
qu engagées par le gouvernement je vous
remercie
merci monsieur thierry repentin ministre
chargée de la formation professionnelle
et de l'apprentissage
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur claude
jeannerot vous avez au cours des
derniers mois avec beaucoup d'autres
parlementaires manifester votre souci
quant à l'avenir de cet outil et vous
avez raison car ce n'est pas n'importe
quel outil installé sur tous les
départements de france grâce à sa
proximité grâce aux capacités
d'hébergement de restauration c'est un
outil qui favorise la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi c'est un outil qui
favorise la formation des jeunes de
france c'est un outil qui favorise la
formation des salariés des entreprises
cent vingt mille salariés chaque année
sont formés permet de leur permettant
soit d'accéder à l'emploi soit de s'y
maintenir
hélas les décisions qui ont été prises
depuis 2004 par les gouvernements
précédents ont malmené cet outil à un
point tel car l'été dernier lorsque nous
avons pris nos fonctions il n'y avait
pas de quoi assurer les payes des neuf
mille trois cents salariés de l'afpa en
juillet dernier c'est incroyable mais
pourtant c'est ainsi le premier ministre
a pris l'engagement dès le mois de
juillet devant les partenaires sociaux
de prendre des dispositions pour assurer
l'avenir de l'avs pas nous avons donc
avec michel sapin agi dans l'urgence
agit vite pour colmater les brèches mais
également avec le souhait de répondre à
cet engagement du premier ministre nous
avons donc favorisées on va dire le
changement de gouvernance de cet outil
en favorisant l'arrivée d'un nouveau
président monsieur baroin qui nous avons
demandé un plan de restructuration de
l'entreprise ce plan de restructuration
a été adopté il ya quelques semaines il
se traduira par le fait qu'il n'y aura
aucun licenciement économique parmi les
9000 salariés de l'afpa cela se traduira
aussi par le fait que le gouvernement a
accepté d'apporter 110 millions d'euros
de fonds propres à l'afpa pour
réinvestir sur son patrimoine
élargir sa palette de formation et enfin
l'état mettra à la disposition de l'afpa
le patrimoine car il est patrimoine
aujourd'hui propriétaire de l'état et
ses l'afpa qui le gérera désormais dams
et messieurs je vais vous le dire
monsieur le sénateur la formation
professionnelle c'est un élément
important de la compétitivité de
l'économie française et de ses
entreprises
c'est aussi un investissement sûr
l'avenir sur les demandeurs d'emploi sur
les jeunes de france pour qu'il favorise
effectivement l'insertion dans
l'entreprise le développement des
compétences en cela à la formation
professionnelle c'est un élément
important des trois priorités du
gouvernement que sont l'emploi les
jeunes
l'investissement sur l'avenir l'afpa
concours à la réussite de ces trois
objectifs
c'est la parole est à madame aude
interview pour le groupe socialiste
apparentés
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
ministre des transports de la mer de la
pêche
nous connaissons votre engagement et
votre pugnacité pour défendre une pêche
durable qui préserve les ressources mais
aussi protège l'environnement et qui
respecte tout autant l'économie littoral
et l'emploi d'autre inquiétude cependant
demeure dans cette politique commune des
pêches sur la question notamment
sensible des rejets en mer le conseil
s'est montré favorable à une mise en
oeuvre progressive en fonction des zones
de pêche
et c'est bien là le minimum que l'on
pouvait être en droit d'attendre
mais comment les pêcheries multi
spécifiques que nous connaissions bien
en bretagne dans bien d'autres régions
françaises pourront elles faire face à
cette demande
l'obligation de débarquement des
captures un désir et ne règle en rien le
problème de la surpêche
elle ne posera pas de problème certes à
certains je rappellerai simplement cet
arraisonnement en décembre dernier d'un
chalutier g en battant pavillon allemand
qui lui ne regrettera certainement pas
si on lui impose zéro rejet puisqu'il
peut embarquer jusqu'à 4000 tonnes de
poissons nous nous refusons ce modèle
économique qu'il ne verrait aucun
inconvénient à la norme zéro rezé en
sacrifiant l'environnement marin sur
l'autel d'une industrie spéculative
cette interdiction des rejets est en
effet une mesure inadaptée et contre
productive qui une nouvelle fois des
montres l'entêtement aveugle de la
commission européenne au détriment de la
ressource et surtout de la sécurité des
pêcheurs
cette mesure favorisera la filière des
farines animales en créant un marché
pour les prises accessoires et ce en
contradiction totale avec les objectifs
environnementalistes déclaré par la
commissaire mallet mme damanaki
à l'opposé de cette politique qui
conduira au déclin d'une pêche
soutenable il faut en priorité
encourager et améliorer la cie
utilité des engins de pêche dans le
cadre d'un plan de modernisation de la
flotte pour des bateaux encore plus sûre
et plus éco responsables dans le cadre
de la procédure de codécision
le parlement européen doit voter le
futur règlement de base le 6 février et
ce dernier sera donc à l'ordre du jour
du prochain conseil de pêche
monsieur le ministre quel sera donc
votre stratégie pour continuer à
défendre une pêche durable laquelle nous
sommes attachés mais aussi nos pêcheurs
et le développement économique de notre
territoire littoraux de chez frédéric
cuvillier ministre chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice oeuvres de thériault
l'actualité est en effet marqué par la
poursuite des discussions au niveau
européen sur la réforme de politique
communautaire de la pêche dans toutes
ses composantes
c'est une réforme et une politique qui
demande la mobilisation politique de
tous les instants et une présence
affirmée au sein des conseils des
ministres de l'union
je dois simplement regretter que ces
dernières années la politique de la
chaise vide et fait que la position de
la france et était affaiblie dans ce
domaine
pour ma part j'ai participé aux travaux
de chacun des conseils des ministres il
y en a eu six et je le ferai encore
lundi prochain je crois en des francs et
que la france et vous y êtes attachés
comme bon nombre d'élus a désormais
retrouvé une certaine forme de
crédibilité dans matière de pêche
vous le savez de nombreuses heures
durant nous avons défendu lors des
derniers conseils de juin et d'octobre
les positions françaises notamment sur
la politique commune des pêches
nous avons obtenu des compromis qui
était difficile à obtenir il était
équilibré notamment sur les aides à la
pêche dans le cadre du fonds européen
pour les affaires maritimes de la pêche
le fait en en juin dernier nous avons
obtenu également de nous avancer
extrêmement positif sur les quotas
individuels et individuels transférables
qui préoccupait les professionnels et la
prise en compte
c'est majeur de l'outre-mer et du
rendement maximum durable
la question des rejets que vous évoquez
dans votre question est une pierre
angulaire de cette réforme et nous
devons avoir conscience qu'une grande
majorité d'états
le parlement européen sont sur des
positions assez éloigné de la position
de la france pour une interdiction
totale d'hergé j'ai bien pris note des
inquiétudes dans votre région d'ailleurs
les professionnels m'avait également
alerter sur les inquiétudes légitimes
avec cette question comment peut-on
concilier ce principe avec l'aménagement
des navires forte anciens avec la
sécurité des navires la sécurité du
travail à bord que faire des rejets qui
sont amenés à terre et vous avez
parfaitement résumé les préoccupations
de ces professionnels nous devons
désormais adopter une approche qui soit
à la fois praticable pour les pêcheurs
mais également extrêmement réaliste qui
donne à la filière le temps pour
s'adapter c'est ce que nous réclamons au
niveau de la commission et auprès de
madame damanaki et de l'ensemble du
conseil européen le compromis adopté au
niveau du conseil de juin permet en
partie de garantir une approche qui est
une approche pragmatique dans le temps
et nous devons encore travailler sur un
certain nombre de points qui sont en
suspens par exemple la date d'entrée en
vigueur de la question de la stabilité
relative
c'est un peu technique mais les
professionnels savent combien cela est
important et nécessaire
ces sujets seront abordés lors des
prochains conseils ce sera le cas en
janvier ce sera également le cas en
février
ces avancées sont obtenus je l'indiquais
à l'occasion d'intenses négociations qui
doivent être désormais formellement
adopté au cours de l'année 2013
à l'issue de discussions avec le
parlement européen puisque vous le savez
la réforme de la politique des pêches
est désormais une réforme et une
politique adoptée en codécision entre le
parlement et le conseil des ministres je
dirais simplement que je fais toute
confiance à la présidence irlandaise et
que le merci johnny thijs terminé pour
défendre les intérêts de ces pêcheurs
merci monsieur françois noël buffet pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'intérieur
la semaine dernière le sénat a rejeté le
projet de loi rebaptisant les
conseillers généraux en conseillers
départementaux et modifiant leur mode
d'élection c'est incontestablement un
camouflet pour le gouvernement qui est
d'autant plus remarquable que ce n'est
pas seulement l'opposition sénatoriale
qui a combattu cette réforme puisque
tous les partenaires de votre majorité
les élus radicaux écologiste ou
communiste ont mêlé leurs voix pour
empêcher l'adoption de cette réforme
ils l'ont fait parce que celle ci
constitue une atteinte grave à la
représentation des territoires ruraux
dans le seul but de favoriser
électoralement les membres d'un parti
politique en l'occurrence le parti
socialiste après vos déclarations
d'amour aux collectivités locales mais
vous savez qu'en la matière il n'ya que
des preuves qui doivent être données on
aurait pu espérer que votre gouvernement
aurait formulé des propositions pour
accompagner la décentralisation pour
améliorer les conditions d'exercice
toujours plus complexes des mandats
locaux
au lieu de ça deux mesures majeures la
première vous avez préféré matraque et
financièrement les collectivités locales
au moment du vote du budget faut-il
rappeler que vous avez ponctionner de
plus de deux milliards d'euros sur
l'ensemble de celles ci à présent vous
voulez modifier les règles électorales
des élections locales à la seule fin
d'être de tenter d'empêcher l'inévitable
sanctions dans les urnes de la politique
est actuellement menée par le
gouvernement
l'égal accès des femmes et des hommes
aux mandats électoraux est un objectif
légitime que par ailleurs nous
partageons bien évidemment mais il doit
être poursuivie sans que cela ne se
fasse au détriment d'autres objectifs
aussi légitime comme le pluralisme et la
représentation de tous les territoires
de la république sous couvert de la
parité vous avez inventé un mode de
scrutin que le monde nous envie
sur mesure pour vous même et sans
équivalent au monde dont le seul objet
est d'affaiblir la représentation des
territoires ruraux
dans certains départements la taille
moyenne des cantons pourra dépasser 75
mille habitants en coupant ainsi tout
lien entre l'élu et ses administrés dans
mon département celui du rhône les
cantons feront 64 mille habitants en
moyenne dans le nord de celui ci la
fusion de six cantons minimum sera
nécessaire pour constituer un
seul nouveau un seul canton couvrira un
tiers du département
à présent que le sénat dont le rôle
conféré par la constitution et de
représenter les collectivités
territoriales de la république a rejeté
ce texte il serait de toute évidence
contraire à l'esprit de nos institutions
que votre gouvernement persiste dans ce
noble dans son aveuglement bien sûr et
tente de passer surtout en force à
l'assemblée nationale un projet de loi
sur les collectivités territoriales
contre l'avis même du sénat et pas
n'importe quel avis puisqu'ils y compris
des voix de votre majorité se sont mêlés
pour ce rejet
dans ces conditions la personne ne veut
de votre réponse d'europe de votre
réforme pardon et cela a été démontré
nous vous demandons de retirer
clairement ce projet de l'ordre du jour
est de représenter une autre copie si
tenté que vous le souhaitiez qu'ils
soient plus conformes aux intérêts de
nos territoires et singulièrement des
territoires ruraux merci merci monsieur
manuel valls ministre d'intérieur seul
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur buffet
prolongeons don de quelques minutes les
32 heures que nous avons passées
ensemble sur ces questions un débat
d'ailleurs de très grande qualité avec
des préoccupations exprimées par les uns
et par les autres ya eu un vote c'est
incontestable ce n'est pas la première
fois et on peut le regretter à l'instar
du président et c'est même ce matin en
tout cas moi ce que je constate c'est
que même si le texte n'a pas été voté et
donc à ce stade il ne s'applique pas
bien évidemment au delà des lectures qui
sont prévues le sénat a cependant adopté
des mesures qui me paraissent
importantes
la suppression du conseiller territorial
il ya une majorité au sénat pour cela
c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer parce
que de toute façon les obligations le
report des élections départementales et
régionales en 2015 ou encore les
nouvelles règles pour l'élection directe
des conseillers communautaires une
élection démocratique c'est d'abord une
élection qui permet à la société d'être
correctement représenté le scrutin
départemental doit donc être strictement
paritaire et c'est l'objectif du
gouvernement qui peut se satisfaire
d'avoir uniquement une représentation
des femmes qui représentent 13 5% des
conseillères générales qui peut admettre
qu'il y ait deux ou trois départements
qui n'ait aucune femme et puis en même
temps nous ne voulions pas présenter un
scrutin qu'ils soient strictement
proportionnelle parce que là aussi ne
permettait pas une bonne représentation
des différents territoires qui composent
un département et puis de toute façon
s'il fallait modifier
s'il fallait rester pardon scrutin
actuel doit être fallu un découpage
c'est un mode de scrutin qui existe
depuis 1800 alors je veux bien croire
que vous soyez attaché au consulat moi
aussi pour un certain nombre de mesures
prises à l'époque par bonaparte mais en
même temps il faut vivre avec son temps
et donc son temps nécessite un certain
nombre de changements et la
représentation démographique elle doit
être clair elle doit être simple doit
être compréhensible par tout le monde et
donc la représentation cantona ne devra
pas s'écarter de la règle fixée par le
conseil d'état
les 20% même si et moi je suis prêt à
desserrer cet étau en introduisant toute
une série d'éléments qui permettent aux
territoires ruraux de la montagne nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure
bref à une bonne représentation
géographique de ces territoires je crois
qu'on pourra avancer là dessus voilà
monsieur buffet votre majorité avait
introduit de la confusion entre le
département et la région
ce gouvernement redonne sa place au
département vous ne tenez pas compte de
la population nous vous rappelons qu'en
démocratie
un homme ou une femme égale une voix
vous aviez choisi un mode de scrutin qui
pénalisait les femmes
nous nous mettons en oeuvre la parité
merci mes chers collègues nous en avons
fini avec les questions d'actualité au
voile a donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement en
direct du sonar on se retrouve tout de
suite pour faire refaire la séance avec
nos invités
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat après la séance des
questions d'actualité aujourd'hui à la
haute assemblée et bien on refait cette
séance avec nos invités